[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it dear
Felicia and Hank it is the weekly
podcast where I hang Corrine and usually
John I don't know if we can even say
usual anymore because it's now been more
not John than John but anyway this week
the amazing Felicia Day answer your
questions give you dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon but first Felicia
do you have a poem for us yeah I do in
fact have a prepared statement a couple
of the sounds that I really like are the
sounds of a switchblade and a motorbike
I'm a juvenile product of the working
class who's the best friend floats in
the bottom of a glass thank you thank
you for that lovely poem written by
Bernie Taupin the man who wrote almost
all of the lyrics to Elton John song and
he's dancing this is the final this is
the final Elton John lyric of dear Hank
and John because John's hiatus will be
ending next week so he will be back but
this week even better than John we have
Felicia how are you doing I'm really
good how are you I'm good we just did
VidCon so I'm a little bit exhausted and
confused and not entirely sure what my
purpose is in life anymore but other
than that just dandy
you have postpartum yeah I got I got
depression I got a little bit of post
vidcon melancholia which is when I go to
comic-con yes and when I go to any
television show that I have because well
I think when you're in any intense
circumstance where you're just literally
living moment to moment when you stop to
reflect the emptiness of life or the
positivity of it you get a little bit
down and that's what we're all about
here at dear Hank and John pausing to
reflect the emptiness of life cheering
let's just do that for the next visit
let's in fact the rest of this episode
is just going to be silence but you are
required as a listener to listen to
these 40 seconds of 40 minutes of
silence during which nothing happens
except that you reflect on the emptiness
of life but I think you should watch a
timer
as you watch that 40 minutes go by to
really remind you of how fleeting life
is because that would make it more
depressing in reality thank you viewer
for listener I suppose for sharing your
time with us because we know that you
have a limited number of moments on this
earth and you have chosen to spend some
of them with us boy is this just the
best humor podcast on iTunes it is it is
under the humour category and I think
we're channeling it right yeah well push
it push it that hard so what have you
been up to in Felisa
you know I've been really busy I have
been I have my book coming out so that's
very intense finishing a book starting
it telling people about it I admire your
brother very much having gone through
this process one time he is the eternal
champion of ginzu in his life in two
pieces in order to accommodate all the
needs of a book other than that he could
sundries going along lots of writing and
in just I feel even even keeled I feel
like my life is planned out enough so
that I don't have to be anxious about it
I just have to live the moments yeah
yeah that's a news I'm glad to hear that
thank you I'm really excited about your
book it comes out if I'm correct August
11th it is it's called your you're never
weird on the internet almost correct
correct and that was a title that took
almost as long as the first draft but I
would love to hear your long list of all
titles which I'm sure is very long and
and awful and annoying to even think
about it there is some truly bad yes
there truly bad really bad office geek
areum I mean just knows how it tends to
be so here on dear Hank and John or as
it may be dear Hank and Felicia what we
do is we answer people's questions that
they have sent us to the email address
dear Hank and John at gmail.com and we
have a number of those to answer today
so I think that it might be time to just
dive in and start doing that do you want
to ask our first question yeah I can do
that
Annie asks dear Hank and Felicia I'm
about to start my junior year of high
school
how do I overcome the overwhelming
sinking feeling thinking about what's to
come this year I am terrified everyone
says it's so hard and very important and
what if I screw up my entire life in the
single year good question yeah I will
say that it is important but I don't
know that it's necessarily so hard but
it is also not so important that if you
if you have a rough go one year of of
any year of your life what a regardless
of the year regardless of you know what
what year in school you are boy can I
guarantee you that that will not mess up
your whole life yeah I agree
I I relate to this question a lot
because I am definitely a perfectionist
I have a perfection syndrome which a lot
of my life disabled me into making the
kind of choices that I think would have
been good for myself because I was
afraid of messing up so I'm not saying
that it's go out and deliberately tank
junior year because it's a very
important to get into a college and do
well on your grades to prepare you for
that phase of your life but I will say
that as an older person a relative to a
junior high school person the the things
that I have learned moat they're our
most valuable in my life have been the
failures not the amazing successes that
I was able to brag to people about yeah
I mean it there's there's a this weird
thing about screwing up that it feels
like the biggest thing in the world when
it happens but it tends to from both the
perspective of of time looking back on
it as as me but also from the
perspective of people around me that
those things are fairly insignificant
like they like that's the real surprise
the surprise isn't so much to me that
like looking back on my past failures
that I don't necessarily consider them
as big of a deal as I did at the time
it's that even at the time the people
around me didn't think that those things
were such soso catastrophic as I did and
really what I was concerned about wasn't
necessarily failing it was being
perceived as a
failure and that I think is is mostly a
usually irrational fear because
oftentimes what I when I see people fail
I almost never think less of them unless
they failed for a reason that that it
has you know it's not it's not so much
about the failure it's that they have
done something that I find like that
that according to my values is is a
little off or skeezy or something so
it's often times when I see people fail
in fact I find that increases my opinion
of them and and I try to think about
that when I mess up or do something
wrong and think about how do I turn this
mess up into you know and not not think
about the way that people are thinking
about me as a screw-up but think about
the way that people are thinking about
me me as someone who's dealing with a
situation that isn't ideal and so like
it yeah I I often you know those are the
moments where you learn the most about
yourself and also the moments where
other people learn a lot about you and
so I mean all of this is to say that
that anxiety about failure is a little
is misplaced because usually the people
who who are judging who you think will
be judging you are in fact right there
with you and probably caught up in their
own their own failure their their own
anxieties and fears about the world and
and think that whatever's happened to
you is you know you you're handling it
well and you're being quite proficient
this is this is my yeah all of my
thoughts on on this on this very very
brief question I mean I think a lot of
it you're right it is anxiety and is a
very anxious person I think it took a
while and maybe just even in the last
year or so where I can comprehend that
no matter if the worst thing in the
world happens nothing ends your life
will still go on you will have different
choices but they may be even better
choices in the long term so you kind of
have to think of your life is I don't
want to say it's a marathon versus a
sprint but
that is a good analogy like you are the
it's like if you go to a restaurant you
love and one time you have a bad meal
but the aggregate of all the meals
you've had at that place are pretty darn
good
obviously I'm not gonna say that place
I'm never going back I mean if you if
there might be people who say I'm never
going back but they might be missing out
on the aggregate of an awesome thing and
that's fine if you don't have that
person or opportunity in your life
anymore I mean I'm definitely not saying
tank your junior year
but I am saying that life goes on and
you will cope and you will have just as
many options to you afterwards they just
will be different for them things that
you're anxious about losing right now
mm-hmm yeah and and just more
specifically junior year's probably
isn't gonna be I mean if you work if you
you know if you're conscious about how
you learn and about and about wanting to
learn then I a lot of people have gotten
through junior year all right so it's
it's something that I I think you can do
Annie I have faith right and junior year
I think is that you should be trying
different things and be willing to fail
knowing that you might like those things
or not like them like this is a perfect
time in your life to figure out what you
want to do a little bit more and and you
have free reign to experiment and right
now it's there there are lower stakes
it's not easy high school but this is a
time you should branch out and feel and
to feel out different opportunities that
you might want to pursue more vigorously
in college so I would say embrace
yourself and try to things that you
might know that will go to go south but
try that's it's really interesting
because we do put a ton of pressure on
young people in high school and in
college and and sort of saying like this
is that like you have to be serious
about your future but really that it is
great to think of it as kind of a more
low stakes time of your life and that's
not what we that's not what the
establishment wants to tell children
because we don't want them to make those
giant mistakes that really can mess up
your life like that that might land you
in in in prison for example that would
that would that might mess
your life pretty hard but yeah this this
uh it really because you don't have
people dependent on you and you and you
don't have to pay your own bills and you
know in a way you're not even dependent
on yourself it is it's it's a time when
when I think that certain risks should
be encouraged rather than prohibited
against at all costs
it's just an interesting way that we
treat young people in our country
because we don't we are terrified and we
don't trust them well I think it's
approaching other people's homework for
you is important but your own homework
for yourself is super important as well
mm-hmm and especially in that time of
life like that is when you should be
free to do some homework figure out who
you are and you will probably try things
you don't like but unless you try them
you won't know and so that's why I
always encourage people jump headfirst
into something and and and at least
you'll be eliminating something for your
going forward in a satisfied way I feel
really good about our answer to that
question what what kind and thoughtful
people we are Felicia know we are people
who have made mistakes who are trying to
be wise God praise has a question for us
she asks dear Hank and Felicia what are
some of your good best friend criteria
oh that's a good question yeah so if
you're gonna have if you're gonna have
or be a best friend what are we looking
out for that's interesting because a lot
of times I've felt like in my life a
best friend isn't necessarily something
I've chosen it's something that kind of
happened to me like like a brother you
know it's just the the person that I
ended up with somehow that's less the
case now as an adult who has made some
more conscious decisions but as a young
person I often felt like I kind of just
I know this isn't entirely true but in a
lot of ways to sort of ended up with the
people who were nearby well that's why
putting yourself in situations and
social spheres is super important and
not settling for one where you I think I
think the core of it is being able to be
yourself efforts effortlessly and not
have to pretend or hide anything you are
because that person if in order to be
quote-unquote best should know the
barest you and still want to like you I
think that's important for a boyfriend
girlfriend or a platonic friends you
yeah I mean I think you shouldn't have
any sense of shame about yourself with a
best friend yeah yeah absolutely like
that there's something so wonderful
about that moment where you realize
where when you realize that people like
you despite the fact that you in my
experience that I don't like me that
much because I'm all up inside of me and
analyzing my own faults and then having
someone be like no I yeah all those all
those things are really great like that
Bridget Jones's Diary moment and for all
the people out there who aren't children
and have seen that movie
and yeah that's at subject that's such a
great way to think about it yeah I know
that and and I think when you think
about it like that you allow yourself
not to have everyone like you and I have
a course a pathological please like me
person I don't know what it is about the
way I was raised but when I feel the
most acutely rejected when I'm don't you
know it doesn't seem like I belong or I
do something that messes up with someone
or I show them an interest that doesn't
fit with them and I get I feel in my
mind that I get rejected which made may
or not be the case so I take that to
heart very very closely but when I
realize that you're not gonna like
everything I don't like beer that
doesn't make me a bad person but that
just means think that's just not for me
and every person is not for every person
so in a it allows you to let go of
things where you're clinging to them and
might more for yourself to be
inauthentic and therefore you're always
acting which is not comfortable or in
the best friend realm it oh yeah and so
I think that as as if I think the right
way to think about this is like how do I
be the best best friend and and really
that's about trying to coax out the real
person from the person that you love the
you know
this friend like coaxing coaxing them
out and like letting them be exactly who
they are mm-hmm and and hopefully really
really liking that person if it turns
out to do you don't really really like
that person don't try to change them
don't try to like mold them into the
thing that you want your perfect best
friend to be it might just not be that
you two should be together all the time
it might be that there are other better
people that have more similar
perspectives and interests to you but
like that's that's the that's the thing
that I'm you know it's it's such a
tremendous gift to someone to try and
help them be be more themselves and be
more comfortable with themselves and
that that's a role that I you know that
I am very grateful to people in my life
for having done for me so if you can try
and do that for other people it is
something that they will probably be
tremendously grateful for and love you
for that's very interesting because
you're saying that I'm thinking about
acting and of course don't be an actor
in a relationship in real life but I
trained in Meisner a lot which is a lot
about not necessarily putting on a
character but being yourself
authentically in the moment with a
script about the other person and I know
the best acting I've ever done was
getting out of my own head and about my
own performance and about what I'm going
through and just focusing on what the
other person was going through and that
really is what the Meisner technique is
about where you're putting all your
focus on the other person and then
you're reacting and allowing yourself to
react naturally caring about that other
person and that's when you really forget
you're acting and you're in the moment
and I think the best acting is you're
creating a relationship with that other
person not acting that you have a
relationship so it's an interesting
analogy you talk about because that is
sort of the real-life version of cool
Meisner acting we got another question
this one is from Cyprus who asks dear
Hank and Felicia I've been having
trouble as of a recent with a person
who's been a bit too friendly I used to
consider him a friend but after a bit of
a falling out I realized that he wasn't
a person that I
really wanted to be associated with so
it's been a few months since then and
he's reached out to me and apologized
and asked if we could be friends again
that all seems fine fine and dandy but
frankly I just don't want to be friends
with him I don't hate him or anything
he's just not somebody I'd like to hang
out with TL DR how do I go about telling
someone that frankly I don't like them
and don't want to be friends with them
again oh that's I mean yeah it is and
it's it's certainly something that I've
dealt with and usually by being like oh
yeah give me a call and then not
answering when they call you know like
that's that's the it's the ghosting you
got a got a ghost um but that doesn't
always work and also it's a little
crappy thing to do it's really hard and
I know I know that I've tried I mean
this is not the same as friendship but
like in a business level it's always the
most persistent people that you're like
I don't want to have lunch with you I
don't want to have lunch with you I
don't
okay fine because you won't go away and
you know you tend to reward the people
if you're busy with who are most
persistent and I frankly been honest
with people and I've been like listen I
just don't have time to do this or do
this favor for you or whatever I don't
have time to give you what you want from
me and the pushback I've gotten has been
just so bad and I'm a very
non-confrontational person so I I don't
know ghosting is my backup plan I guess
in life and business and personal
because I just don't know how else you
deal with it and and not leave a tainted
sort of taste in your mouth with another
person's feelings who just won't get the
hint yeah I mean there's a certain
amount of you have to be careful and
make sure that this person isn't
basically trying to manipulate you and
and being disrespectful of you if if you
are if you think you are being clear
that they that that you don't want to
chill with them anymore and they aren't
taking the hint it may be that they are
trying to willfully manipulate you and
is you know in in business that's a kind
of thing that you sort of have to deal
with in personal life that shouldn't be
a thing that you have to deal with yeah
and and in that circumstance then you
know you might you might want to look
out for a sort of a pattern of
manipulation in this person to make sure
that that they're just trying to be
friends again and they they're you know
have good motives rather than they're
trying to control you because when
people are trying to control you that is
very much a situation where you want to
be like look I'm just cutting this off
it's not gonna happen
yeah oh also it's it's it sounds like
it's driven by their ego whether they
Amin what is it that they won from you
are you really was it was it a very
special friendship like I I guess this
is this is a question of like what level
of intimacy of friendship was there and
what was the motivation for falling out
and was it a situation where you've
grown past that person and that
circumstance for being close to them or
something a you know bad happened and
you want to separate yourself and
they're just desperately trying to cover
their own ego but even dreaming
themselves regardless of what your
feelings are and needing space to get
over it like it sounds like when
somebody is like that either they have a
true problem in reading other people's
you know reactions in which you might
actually just have to be honest and and
say I can't hang out I need time or I'm
just really busy or they're just driven
by their own ego and you shouldn't feel
bad about just kind of not responding
because hopefully eventually they'll
move on right if they're trying if it
feels like they're trying to control you
then you should have no qualms about
controlling your own destiny and and
basically just ignoring them and if it
goes beyond that if they keep bugging
you
then that's like a legitimate
circumstance where you need to be you
need to be straight up and be like and
basically say look this isn't a
relationship that I'm interested in
having I've got lots of stuff going on
and you're not part of it and it's just
gonna have to be that way it's very that
is extremely hard I've had to do it a
couple times it's extremely unpleasant
there's nobody I don't know that any
good at it except for maybe people who
are just just have zero anxiety and
inside of them but but where those
moments where you say look this is how
it's going to be and that's a little bit
like you know a breakup where you're
saying this like no we can't be friends
we have to break up
we're friend we're friend breaking up
and and I don't need to explain why
because I'm living my life and you can
live yours but whether or not I'm a part
of your life is my decision just like
whether or not yeah like like you can't
have you can't you know like your
desires do not affect my desires and so
I don't need to tell you why this is
over it just is and you have to accept
that and a lot of times with
particularly manipulative people if you
give them a reason then they're just
gonna be like oh well we can fix that
but it yeah it might not be about there
being a reason it might just be about
you not wanting to chill with them
anymore and that's fine like you not
liking their values you not liking them
you sensing something off about them
that you don't want to have in your life
and that's fine and you should totally
go with your instincts and and you
should not feel a responsibility to tell
that person all the reasons or delet
cushion that blow or whatever it's you
know it's your life and and you should
be able to control yourself
I feel like just listening to your
strengths is making me a what you're
talking about is making me anxious just
thinking about a scenario totally right
I mean I've never I've never broken up
with with a friend like that I've never
had a business thing that I could ever
say to some of these face I just don't
want to do this anymore like and and
that is a and I think that's part of my
being homeschooled like I did not deal
with confrontation or rejection as much
as I should have as a kid and I
I love the fact that you're encouraging
that and everyone to be strong enough to
stand up for yourself
really and control the relationship
strings that are attached to you in life
because if not you know it weighs you
down and I think especially in modern
times where we can't get away from our
friends from college or high school or
elementary school because we are tied to
them in an online fabric
that is easy to cut off but persistently
there where people can enter your life
again I think it's even a bigger issue
to talk about so thank you for lending
me strings and cypress as well
yeah and it's it mean it gives me
anxiety to to talk about it and not even
having to do it it's not something I've
had to do in a long time which is nice
yeh yeah yeh strength but I mean there
are definitely like business
relationships I have where I would love
to say that but in business it's
different because it's not a like
because everybody sort of shares
business like everybody shares an
industry and and we all have to you know
live together inside of our industry but
with with personal stuff it isn't like
it has to be a you know mutually agreed
upon relationship and if one person
doesn't want to be in it then the
relationship doesn't exist anymore like
that's how relationships work yeah but
as you know it's we are in a weird world
and when you're in an entertainment
business is personal and personal is
business frequently and as someone who's
gone through a lot of iterations of what
I do and having personal relationships
move on and business relationships move
on in various good and bad ways it is
very difficult and you you know if
something goes wrong everyone's the hero
of their own tale and you're not going
to be the hero in everyone's tale and so
the only thing you can do is what your
gut is telling you is the right thing
for you in and and that includes your
moral fabric and that you're not really
messing somebody over or really hurting
their feelings so it's complicated but
yeah it's even more complicated when
business and personal mix yeah it sure
is fun
caris asks dear Felicia and Hank I was
wandering through a nearby forest and
was thinking about grouped group can
only say one thing but can express
emotion when he says it my question to
you is would you rather only say one
thing but express emotion as you want
when you say it like Groot or say
whatever you want but be unable to
express any mo
oh boy
well the question is can I say like I am
very mad right now or alike can i
express can I can I can say whatever I
want
yeah I can express emotion in that way
just I wouldn't be able to like it would
be difficult to believe for me to be
like I am so mad right now
I have never been this angry in my life
and this is the most angry I've ever
been and no and whatever but no one
could believe you no one would we would
be very difficult to say to someone like
I love you but without any emotion ever
being shown in your relationship with
that person
and they would just have to believe you
know no one would know for sure whether
you were scared or not you'd have to be
like I'm very scared yeah I don't I mean
that would be very Spock like and that
you can't I mean because she says or he
you would be unable to express any
emotion which means your face which is a
vehicle to unspoken emotion would not be
able to express it at all so you're
you're completely expressionist in your
face and body I mean if you're unable to
express does that mean you can't hug
someone so that would be a very bad
world I think yeah yeah I mean I I
started out I started out being being I
would want to be able to commit to say
whatever I want but I've come I've come
around to the other perspective
especially because I and I believe those
around me would be happy to learn sign
language and express emotion that way so
boom check that out true and not around
the intera dock technically in the
question you could write you could only
say it like Groot the only one you could
would you rather only say one thing but
express emotion as you want when you say
it and then that I mean maybe I'm just
Percy maybe I'm being a lawyer I've
watched too much Good Wife lately I'm
parsing this question you should you
really should have phrased this question
more carefully because the way we read
it this yeah either way could be either
way it's really there's it's full of
loopholes
Swiss cheese is a Swiss cheese question
so I would say the grouped group being
able to say emotion and then be able to
hug people cuz I like hugs that's good
that's good though we are both employed
as professional speakers of words but
what what good would it be if we could
only speak words without emotion that
you'd get no no more acting jobs for
Felicia yeah true true no acting
although writing you could be well
unable to express any emotion let's
let's just theoretically say that you
couldn't speak emotion but you could
write emotion so then actually that
limitation might make you the best
composer or writer in the world because
you have to channel everything into your
expression your your art so actually I
don't know now I'm on the fence again
turns out this is a really complicated
question I I was just thinking earlier
today I was having a conversation with
some friends about how superheroes and
we're talking about I'm talking about
superheroes right now that have special
abilities how they how they choose to
make the world a better place this is
often seems very it's it's big and it's
explosive and it's about like you know
attacking and defeating evil but it
isn't really the way that good gets done
in the world mm-hmm
and maybe this there maybe there's
something like we're talking about
Superman maybe there's something in this
sort of morality of Superman that
prevents this but he has the ability to
do so much good in just sort of like
infrastructure creation and like he
could just you know heat up balls of
stuff with his heat vision and then use
that to power power plants without the
production of fossil fuel or without the
burning of fossil fuels and and solve
global warming sort of in one stroke but
I bet there's some like weird
mythological thing with Superman that
says like according to the laws of
Krypton he can't do that I mean I
particularly I'm not a big superhero fan
I because I find I mean this is very
probably gonna be controversial but you
know
yes they can do great deeds but they are
not emotionally mature to me as it don't
seem to me no it would be a terrible
thing it's it's almost it's almost as if
they all act like teenage boys Wow it's
true absolutely and they don't know how
to express themselves so they just say
I'm gonna know the building I don't know
that's why I'm not I mean well in your
just an a cursory grants would you say
that any superhero has the emotional
acumen to solve a problem with words and
emotion versus just big actions I
wouldn't say that anybody particularly
springs to mind in my mind I think
there's probably some some some x-men
x-men I was about to say yeah rogue I
mean some of the more psychological
Kitty Pryde maybe yeah you're right yeah
but you know that's that's a that's a
big and I think I think I think a lot of
superhero mythologies have come a long
way in the last like 10 years or even
even five years in terms of like a more
of a fuller view of of the of the
universe and and of human interaction
just because a lot of comic readers have
grown up a bit yeah but yeah it's almost
like the evil ones have more
psychological motivation like I can't
imagine yes in America or Superman it
would be would be able to have a really
good relationship you know relationship
discussion but you know somebody who's a
bad guy I sure you could like deal with
your issues he probably wouldn't come to
your side but at least you know you're
gonna have a good conversation about it
cuz they're a little bit more savvy well
yeah I mean that's it it seems as if you
know villains writers need to create
more motivation for villains and so they
sort of create they're the sort of
internal mythology of the vet like the
villains internal mythology more fully
than they create the heroes because the
hero the motivation is is more explicit
it's more obvious to the reader it's
yeah but it's extremely motivating
because of that I it's it's interesting
I often hear people saying like I kind
of identify with villains more than with
heroes because like I you know I like I
get that I get where they're coming from
and like
Oh like the world is so messed up and
why not just why not just destroy all of
it which you know it's really it's it's
always great when you see a hero dealing
with that when you see you know watchman
is a really good example of a comic that
has just a ton of a ton of like really
deeply flawed heroes who who despite the
fact that the world might be coming to
an end they're basically just like I
could fix this problem but boy am i sad
and I don't want to that's maybe why I
love Watchmen yeah
Watchmen is pretty great that that was a
complete non sequitur that had nothing
to do with any of the questions that we
were asked so we're gonna ask another
one this one is from Lauren who asks
dear Hank and Felicia I recently read
that the curiosity Mars rover is
programmed to sing happy birthday to
itself once a year I'm feeling too lazy
to research this could you confirm
whether or not this is true and also do
you think that you would sing happy
birthday to yourself if you lived all
alone by yourself on another planet I
can in fact confirm that the Curiosity
rover does sing happy birthday to itself
once a year on on the anniversary of its
landing on Mars which is just adorable
that's really adorable I want to hear it
is it what kind of cute little voice is
it or is it just like a chip tone thing
oh yeah it's a chip tone thing yeah oh
my gosh that's adorable I'm pretty sure
I mean that's what I imagined I I didn't
I don't know maybe it maybe it's just
the recording of a child singing happy
birthday which would be way creepier
really creepy if you're an alien I just
think that's a that was such a great
like afterthought kind of thing it's
like well I mean why is there even a
speaker on it I'm sure there's a reason
that it has a speaker there's probably a
really great scientific reason that that
the Curiosity rover needs to have
speakers and I don't know what that
would be but I'm sure there is one and
so once you have it you can be like hey
you know it'd be great you know like let
people talk more about curiosity like
give us another opportunity to have a
press release go out let's have it sing
happy birthday to itself it would be
great if you were able to submit your
own you know voice remember in in the
old
days they had that computer voice that
you could program in and you would just
make it say things if you type them in
to the browser mmm I mean that was
amazing so if you had people bid for
charity in order to be able to say I'm
gonna have the curiosity to speak on you
know I love it I love it yeah I just
like send a message to Curiosity rover
and have it be like butt fart fart butt
[ __ ] fart fart fart fart fart butt fart
butt and that would be that's it'd be so
good I would totally how much money
would I pay to have Curiosity rover just
say the word fart three times on the
surface of Mars I would I would pitch
them for that if we do have and I'm I'm
a donor have what's what's your what's
your number that like how like what's
your highest number I would pay I would
pay a thousand thinking a thousand I was
thinking somewhere between five hundred
thousand I mean that's an upper limit
but if we went in five hundred eight
thousand dollars that's yeah yeah I mean
my firt my first thought was like it was
five hundred but then I was like would I
pay more than that yes I'd pay seven
hundred would I pay 800 yes and then I
got to a thousand then I was like yes
and then eleven hundred I was like oh
yeah so so I feel like around a thousand
dollars I would pay to have to have the
Mars River just just say fart a few
times and annek apparently Felicia wants
the same thing so we can just I think I
think we know enough people collectively
that we could definitely yeah if anybody
listening to the podcast right now has
the ability to get curiosity to say
words for us we've got a thousand
dollars for you what did you charity to
charity I think it should go to like a
you know oh okay it should go yeah right
right not free not for you it's like you
know under the under the table quoting
honestly I don't care what it goes to
I'll get I anything if it's for charity
I would pay even more but but a thousand
dollars I'd I'd pay just just you know
Jeff from NASA said to do that he's
gonna get him fired now it's gonna be
some kind of extortion ring at JPL all
right there the second component of this
question was do you think you'd sing
happy birthday to yourself if you lived
all alone on another planet yes because
I saw castaway and Tom Hanks got crazy
hair
from loneliness and I I think that
benchmarks are important in life and if
I were to just say to hell with it I
would probably be a dirty very uncut
lady at the end and just kind of die
sadly without any any sort of highlights
to my my island yeah planet I I think
it'd be hard to keep track of the days
if nobody else was around but I guess if
I had a smartphone you know it would do
it for me because one assumes that if
you're on it on another planet you've
got like you've got stuff keeping you
alive it has like the date and time on
it so yeah I I don't know that I would
sing happy birthday to myself but I
would definitely celebrate my birthday
if I was mentally together enough to do
that
if I was in my current state I would but
probably by the time my birthday rolled
around rolls around next May if like
suddenly I was by myself on another
planet just this the solitude probably
would have gotten to my head by that
point and I I wouldn't be in the state
to be able to do much of anything I
don't know though maybe I'd keep really
busy on Mars maybe I'd be super into
Mars and just like a look at rocks all
day that's eventually I probably would
get tired of the rocks but not but not
for a while I mean I would carve in the
rocks because I mean I I guess if I
always get angry at people who carve in
trees when I'm hiking I'm like who are
you well I don't care about your love
but if I was on Mars I would be
vandalizing some rocks to say like I was
here and nobody would care who came
after me but I would feel satisfied to
leave my imprint there yeah yeah yeah
I'd probably you know you just build
like giant cairns of Mars rocks so
people in the future come along and be
like what on earth and he'd be like look
there was this hypothetical in a podcast
and somehow it came true and like I got
here I can't explain all of that I just
we're just like right like I'm basically
a novel with rocks just like setting out
pebbles the VA like here's here to
explain the entire thing here's a five
thousand word essay written in pebbles
that would be that would be that would
be a life chore worth living yeah
absolutely
that would be electing I want to read
your pebble novel our next question
Sarah asks dear Felicia Hank if you
could be transported into the world of a
video game
which game world would you most like to
explore and why oh I love this question
this is hard because yeah I put this
quote I put this question in because I
thought that you would it you would
enjoy it but I completely forgot to come
up with an answer for myself so you're
gonna have to go first
well I mean I actually forgot to come up
with answer even though when I read the
it in the email I was like oh this is
very exciting I I mean it's gonna be
hard because most places in video game
worlds don't have toilets ever so you go
in and you're like there's no toilet
here how do they go to the number one
number two I think I would be very torn
between two different I would be torn
between a fantasy world and a science
fiction world so mmm-hmm you know and
every every video game has disaster
happening all the time so like for
instance Mass Effect's if I were in Mass
Effect if I were in Mass Effect's sorry
and I people were trying to blow up my
planet that would be an unpleasant
experience although I would have to be a
very rich lucrative person and there so
I would have my own ship I would have a
very diverse peer group of different
species I would be able to travel around
all the time but if I were to be sort of
an alien just on a ship I don't know
that seems appealing but not a hundred
percent so I I probably would want to
live in a fantasy world like Skyrim or
even World of Warcraft because it has
bright colors and even though I don't I
think there's there's not a lot of
bathrooms in there but I think we could
we could fix it we could we could crafts
it yeah yeah main concern is do you guys
have soft fluffy downy toilet paper and
yeah that would be super impressed and
and down pillows yeah I mean if you yeah
if you take out the chaos that is in
inherently in video games in that
there's always confrontation and warning
explosions if you take that out and just
say okay you're just living in the world
like a regular person it would be a tie
between Mass Effect and probably well
yeah I I was just thinking about do you
ever the game Space Quest I love that
would you play the janitor yeah yeah so
like Space Quest 6 I think was the last
Space Quest and it
that it was the sort of most involved
one and oh so we can like that the good
thing about Space Quest is like it's
it's really like this is just a bunch of
dopes in space be and dopey funny jokes
bright colors
you know like pixel animation and and
there's just not a lot like like the
worst thing that's gonna happen to is
you're gonna get kicked out of space
school like it's my god now that I'm
saying this I really want to let's play
this game it's so like yeah that that I
am into that but the other thing is that
like most media properties have video
games so like my immediate thought is
like to take me to the Star Trek
universe I'll live there and and there's
plenty of Star Trek video games so like
yes transport me to Star Trek land and
and and I will I will live in the next
generation I will be an innocent very
good I'm the starship yeah
enterprise and I'll be perfectly happy
they have toilets there and there's the
everybody seems to be happy and
fulfilled and adventures happen but very
few people die in the next generation
the whole I probably would want to make
sure I was a recurring character because
I guess a fair number of people do die
right right you would not want to be a
red unitard you want to be a more yellow
er yes exactly so that's that's uh
that's my cheesy answer which is that
there there are indeed Star Trek games
and that's where I've always wanted to
live my whole life that's funny I wanted
to marry Riker from a very young age so
I wanted to be Wesley Crusher really oh
yeah he was my fav I did my hair like
Wesley I yeah I he was so smart you know
everything and everybody like respected
him like an adult he was perfect
character for me I understand why other
people were not a big fan of Wesley but
it was oh I know I liked him I liked him
and I wanted to be you know his mom was
so pretty because I loved her red hair I
was just kind of in love with Riker the
in a way that no there was no one else
existing for me and you know and when I
met Jonathan Frakes at a party I was
kind of intimidated I was like oh god
hi can I get the Doritos I mean I really
was just it's not that's beautiful
that's beautiful I love it very much all
right we're gonna we're gonna move on to
the news this is gonna be the news from
both Mars the fourth Rock from the Sun
and AFC Wimbledon the fourth tier
English soccer team so Felicia do you
have any obscure British football news
for us
I do indeed I was given this piece of
news and just recently learned that
football is soccer so let me let me so
this is super super from my records not
okay
so Neil Ardley Wimbledon's magnificent
and talented manager got a bit upset
during a friendly game between AFC
Wimbledon and the Spanish Granada FC due
to some overzealous refereeing Ardley
was quoted saying the ref started to
book players for nothing at all and the
lads from both sides lost their heads of
it he blew the whistle for the slightest
touch and it was difficult to get any
rhythm in the game in all it was a shame
and I don't know how often both an
English team and a Spanish team have
been upset with a referee that is the
most sports that's ever coming out of my
mouth well I'm proud proud to have been
responsible for all those sports that
just came out of your mouth many many
sports I've been to Grenada and it is a
beautiful city so I did feel like at
least touched a little bit of home in my
heart I really don't know I wrote that I
just you know went to Google News and I
search for AFC Wimbledon and that was a
thing and most like 90% of that was just
a quote from knee largely which was
exactly how the article was written in
whatever publication it was written in
it was basically just this is the thing
that a guy said and and I really like I
I still don't understand what they're
talking about so I apologize if I messed
that up in any way but for some reason
he was upset that a referee and now you
know that thing about AFC Wimbledon on
Tamar's news there was a lot to choose
from this week in Mars news I'm going to
give you a story that podcast listeners
might actually be able to get involved
with themselves the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter has been taken a lot of pretty
tastic pictures of Mars so many that
mission scientists are calling on
volunteers to help them identify and
classify fascinating and peculiar
formations near the southern pole of
Mars marking them for future research
aah barking them for future research
these features flat these features are
left behind during the southern summer
on Mars when dry ice Sublime's off of
the surface leaving weird spider-like
formations and channels and holes you
can learn more about this project
including how to participate at the
planet for terrains website which is at
terrains dot planet for dot org and
that's pla and ET fo you are org and
that is our episode of dear Hank and
John without John but guest hosted by
Felicia Day the creator of many
wonderful things including the entire
geek and sundry YouTube network and
author of you're never weird on the
internet almost out August 11 and
available for pre-order now yay thank
you for having me oh I am I am delighted
I am always and in my review and to hang
out virtually with you and audio fun is
a big treat oh so thank you that's very
sweet it is a huge treat for me as well
and it's going to be also a huge treat
for our editor Nicholas Jenkins who is a
big Felicia Day fan thanks Nick
so thanks Nick our our theme music is by
gunnarolla Nick of course Nicholas
Jenkins is our editor if you have any
questions for us you can send them to
Hank and John at gmail.com and as we say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]